I need it all
Sophie in it tell me Happy Happy
Valentine's Day that feeling in your
heart is Cupid's arrow and definitely
not from a vaccine
who knows you'll be dead by then but we
got a Valentine's Day card from a very
important person today and it's our
favorite VP take it away Kamala
hey Valentine there's a time to
celebrate Valentine's Day and that time
is now for celebrating because it's the
time
[Laughter]
I love Kamala
how sweet of her I think she sent a few
here's another
hi Valentine thanks for the candy but I
would have preferred a Venn diagram and
a yellow school bus you could see with
your own eyes
[Applause]
love Kamala
last one
hey Valentine
[Laughter]
[Applause]
love Kamala that works
she's a delight all right
let's talk about mayor Pete you know the
guy
ah wow rush to judgment here
guy with a round head goofy face Flappy
ears you see him and keep wondering
where to insert the batteries yeah
obviously he's Transportation secretary
when he's not home on paternity to leave
pumping out breast milk
but he's the mediocre mayor who's never
around when you need him you've heard
about the train derailment outside East
Palestine Ohio if you haven't here's a
recap
and same video out of East Palestine a
small town Eastern Ohio near the PA
border a freight train carrying
hazardous material crashed and burst
into flames on Friday night it's still a
problem residents within a one mile
radius order evacuate last night the
mayor there declaring a state of
emergency
excellent recap Bill his briefs are
amazing
so that happened a week and a half ago
thousands of gallons of toxins spilled
worse than an episode of The View
here's a list of what came out it's
pretty scary is that the recipe for
lethal injection or what's in Jesse
Waters hair
bottom line
like female drivers that can kill you
and when
Oh I thought I thought I could slip that
one in
but when combined it's a gas so noxious
even Eric swalwell would demand you
crack a window
animals falling sick and dying people
reporting sudden headaches Burning
Sensations in their eyes sounds like
Eagles fans after the Super Bowl
[Music]
since had to be evacuated in a
controlled burn of the toxins was done
last week so you know what's bad when
the best option is let's set this on
fire and hope for the best according to
one hazardous material specialist they
nuked the town to get a railroad open
which seems like a hell of a decision to
make that's like cutting off your whole
arm because you once shook hands with
Brian Kilmeade
hahaha
so you think the transportation
secretary would have been on the case
ASAP no it wasn't until last night that
he said something 10 days later tweeting
that he continues to be concerned about
the family's impacted and that the EPA
is monitoring the air quality that
sounds like real concerned all he left
out was your call is important to us
please stay on the line
such a robot and while this was going on
what was he talking about Instead This
we have heard way too many stories from
Generations past of infrastructure where
he got a neighborhood often a
neighborhood of color that finally sees
the project come to them but everyone in
the hard hats on that project looking
like uh you know doing doing the good
paying jobs don't look like they came
from anywhere near the neighborhood you
got that too many construction workers
are whites except he doesn't even have
the balls to even say the word White
dude if that bothers you so much why not
give your job to a black guy we we know
it would be a guaranteed Improvement
I'll do it there you go Tyrus is in
so instead of addressing how the Ohio
derailment will affect the nearby Town
businesses Farmers the supply chain he's
talking race it's another example of
chasing a non-problem at the expense of
real problems yes we have a shortage of
pilots and planes are experiencing
near-misses but at least the flight
attendants uniforms are non-binary
sure mystery objects violate our
airspace and transfer derailing but the
real problem is the lack of diversity of
those hard hats wolf whistling at women
while scratching their balls outside a
porta potty
although I bet Pete couldn't find one
person who ever complained about a
construction worker's skin color of
course a few more chemical clouds and
all the workers will be the same color
green and gray
wokeism seems to me the real toxic spill
infecting everything ignoring problems
and offering no Solutions he also made
this dumb joke it's had his challenges
right I mean if you look at what the
American Transportation Systems have
faced in the last two or three years
partly because of the pandemic we've
faced issues from container shipping to
airline cancellations now we got
balloons that's right
um
stick to your day job pal even if it's
as fake as your bicycle commute you
think you'd realize a conference on
infrastructure would be a good time to
address this is even aware there are
also two more derailments on Monday or
that more than a dozen are derailed this
year and that's not counting the ones
from Amtrak when they give Joe the keys
a Pete's nowhere to be found
remember the flight out of Hawaii that
nearly plunged into the ocean happened
in December but now we hear about it
turns out aloha means hello farewell and
kiss your macadamia nuts goodbye
every time there's an emergency Pete
turns into Amelia Earhart he vanishes
faster than massage oil in Larry
kudlow's apartment
even IL
ha Pete saying we need Congressional
inquiry and direct action for people to
judge to address this tragedy hell I'm
starting to like her
although Omar if a yellow brother it
shouldn't be in the bedroom
turn a phrase
It's still nuts this guy got this job
but like so many other bad leaders he
took the right box for the Dems and it's
never the one marked competence it's
identity politics at its worst and we
all pay the price he faked riding a bike
then showed up in an SUV a military
plane flew his husband to their european
vacation and now he acts like a
derailment in chemical spills someone
else's problem you know I'm thinking the
best day for America is transportation
will be when mayor Pete gets run out of
town on a rail
let's welcome
can I get
she's a ratings giant who's always
defiant star of the new Fox Nation
special cancel this Roseanne Barr
yes finally his Valentine's plans are
buying half-price candy tomorrow actor
writer and comedian Jamie listow
she buys roses for the thorns
and finally Lions claim they have the
heart of a Tyrus my massive sidekick in
the NWA World Heavyweight Championship
Roseanne this has been my dream to have
you on this show oh thank you yes and I
don't dream very much when I do it's
about you oh cool congrats on the
special thank you very much it is so fun
yeah so can you give us a quick summary
a sound bite what uh what it is for the
viewers at home who are probably still
sober well it's kind of you know my
first uh my first shot to explain myself
and and kind of come back and uh you
know kind of even the score with the uh
massive idiots and hypocrites who tried
to my life
there we go
but with jokes yes with jokes exactly
and uh I I dug really really deep into
my soul to uh to find the most offensive
way of saying the things I want to say
because I think it's very important that
we uh we try to preserve free speech in
America and by doing so I I believe that
by being offensive to the most offensive
people and power structure that's ever
existed in this country I'm doing my
part
there you go come on
now
I don't even care about your opinion on
train derailments
there's been hundreds of us I know how
glad we don't know this I don't know
they're not telling us anything I know
thank God I don't take the train though
so it's not a problem man no big deal
but no big deal yes exactly but it's all
our food I mean it's all our oil and our
chickens our eggs you know what they're
trying to kill us nobody's just telling
the truth they're trying to kill us all
exactly
all right
and I for want him against that I'm
against it too I'm gonna take a stand I
am against being murdered by the state
you cat I'm also against that are you
against the Pirates well I'm gonna work
for the state
you guys
[Laughter]
hey personal Greg
I see I'm down for whatever yeah I bet
you are how's it going what's your take
on what's happening in Ohio I don't know
anything about trains but I feel like
that guy should just slow down on the
curves
do you know what I mean like it's a
track I just feel like it's a very easy
job you can read a book
um this whole by the way first of all
happy Valentine's Day years I like to
call it um happy
um even lonelier than normal day
for me uh you saw that one of these
balloons was um was up in Alaska did you
see that yeah don't you feel like at
some point like they go oh there's like
a spy balloon I feel like if it's white
and it's slowly floating I feel like
that's just a balloon balloon
is it really a spy if it's like so
obvious did you I heard when the first
balloon got shot down Biden was like so
is it a boy or a girl
thank you
that's funny
okay there I don't know yeah and do we
do we need to like put you know do we
need like fighter jets shouldn't we
could have sent a guy with darts yes
perhaps like it's a waste of resources
yeah you probably should have stopped
after that other joke I should have um
that's how it all started yes that plane
thing scared me though right the um the
plane almost like landed right but I
feel like they took off in the middle of
a storm and I feel like this is like a
lesson to people do you know what almost
crashed at the beginning of the flight
and then it almost crashed at the end as
you know that like right when they took
off it almost crashed into the ocean
from Hawaii then they flew all the way
and it almost crashed again it happened
two times on the same flight that's 100
true and some people say like we don't
know how it happened I heard the pilot
uh he he plugged in Biden's approval
rating
that was a long yeah that was a long
Voyage talking about a play trip he put
into work he put in the work work all
right cat talk about infrastructure I
would love to yes you have some data
yeah I'm riddled with data no that's
nothing
so you made the joke in the monologue
about how ridiculous it was for him to
take such a long paternity leave right
because he's a guy yeah but I think the
bigger joke is he took a long paternity
leave and it took us like two months to
notice he was gone that's true who among
us could be that unnecessary yeah right
uh I didn't I couldn't get away with
that yeah yeah and so am I more
important than he is I mean I think so
so I think he should resign and then I
also think no one should replace him
exactly
Department of Transport we didn't have
this Secretary of Department of
Transportation until 1966 and we were
fine I mean all the way till you were
like 20 years old we were fine
but yeah the uh
she's got a point though I mean if you
think about it Department of Homeland
Security started after 9 11. that one
too that was temporary everything that's
temporary becomes permanent Iris it's
not right
nothing has to be right Greg yeah it's
true and let's go back to that awesome
Point yeah we should get all the
construction jobs
even though we don't know what the
we're doing which is give us the job so
we can wear cut off shirts and hard hats
and be like how's this work
foreign
I I personally when it comes to my home
dwelling don't care what color you are
as long as it works it keeps the rain
out in the heat in so
but again as the new soon to be director
of Transportation
yeah don't Don't Clap too loud because
you don't know what my agenda is
all the women are losing their license
Greg
[Applause]
Alexis would say yeah
yes we stopped using that because we
just figured like people would know by
now they'd figure it out yeah or would
they I don't know
well I think we've learned almost
something today we still don't know what
he does we don't know what he does and
we don't know what's in the balloons and
we don't know why the Train derailed we
know nothing about that and when you ask
you're guilty of noticing something
absolutely they're like you're somehow
being nosy they're all connected it's
none of your business to know what's
happening in the world around you yeah
exactly exactly exactly all right we got
to move on we even have weirder stuff
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else